est ce que vous vous êtes déjà demandé
pourquoi la musique sonne juste
bien au contraire peut sonner faux si
par exemple on joue sur un instrument
qu'est désaccordé et pourquoi il n'ya
que 12 notes de musique et pas 9 17 ou
bien 42
est-ce que douce c'est juste un choix
arbitraire culturel et bien non la
question du nombre de notes et de la
manière dont on accorde les instruments
sont liés et pour le comprendre
on va construire la musique en repartant
de zéro et en fabriquant nous mêmes les
notes dont on a besoin et on va voir que
tout repose sur la physique des
instruments mais aussi sur une égalité
mathématiques incroyable trois
puissances 12 égale deux puissances 19
alors en fait non si vous êtes un peu
matheux vous savez que cette égalité
elle peut pas être vrai une puissance de
3 peut pas être égal à une puissance de
2 mais elle est presque vrai et c'est ce
presque qui cause tant d'ennuis au
musicien depuis des siècles pour m'aider
à reconstituer cette histoire musicale
j'ai demandé à velet de tapas de la
chaîne le cette barre et de venir
m'aider un peu salubre l'aide qu'il nous
présente la chaîne salut david
alors oui c'est dans mes cordes assez
drôle parce que bahia des instruments à
cordes
or donc le cette barre et c'est la
chaîne la musicologue passionné par son
boulot et par le jeu vidéo c'est moi j'y
fais pas mal d'analystes de thèmes
vidéoludique mais aussi des vidéos sur
des sujets musicaux un peu plus généraux
par exemple dernièrement j'ai sorti une
nouvelle série qui parle de la voix fait
qu'il s'agit de mon instrument principal
est que je l'enseigne et puis sur cette
chaîne et bah je fais de la musique
aussi plaints parce que je serais super
triste si j'ai étudié la musique sans la
pratiquer et voilà alors allez vous
abonner à sa chaîne et maintenant que
les présentations sont faites
on peut y aller
[Musique]
commençons par la base physique leçon ce
sont des ondes de vibration de l'air qui
peuvent être créées soit par un objet
qui bouge par exemple une corde soit par
de l'air qui rentrent en résonance par
exemple dans un tuyau d'orgue la hauteur
du son le fait qu'ils soient élus ou
grave est liée à la fréquence de cette
vibration qu'on mesure en hertz
quand la fréquence est faible le son est
grave et plus la fréquence est élevée ou
le sang sera aiguë si on prend une corde
tendue par exemple une corde de guitare
la fréquence de vibration va dépendre du
diamètre de la corde de sa longueur et
sa tension est donc en jouant sur ces
paramètres on peut produire des sons à
la fréquence qu'on veut imaginons que la
musique n'existe pas qui est pas
d'instrument panne note pas d'aurélie
façonne rien du tout est-ce qu'on peut
créer un instrument qui sonne bien juste
à partir de principes physiques et ben
on va essayer
supposons qu'on est juste une seule
corde tendue bien un seul client d'orgue
si vous voulez qu'ils produisent un son
à une certaine fréquence on va prendre
ce sont comme base et pour la suite peu
importe cette fréquence de départ ce que
je vais raconter va fonctionner mais
pour simplifier les calculs on va
imaginer que cette fréquence de départ
c'est 440 hertz
ceux qui connaissent la musique savent
peut-être que cette fréquence c'est ce
qu'on appelle normalement un là mais on
a dit qu'on allait repartir de zéro et
oublier toutes ces camps sur un donc
cette note on va simplement l'appeler
note numéro un
bon voilà bah j'ai un instrument avec
une note
ça va être dur de faire de la musique
avec ça comment je fais pour créer
d'autres notes on va partir de principes
physiques quand un objet vibre ou bien
une cavité résonne avec une certaine
fréquence f
eh ben il vibre aussi naturellement
toujours un peu à la fréquence doublent
2f
c'est ce qu'on appelle la seconde
harmonique donc notre corde initial qui
vibre à 440 hertz
elle produit aussi naturellement un peu
de son à 880 hertz donc si on ajoute à
notre instrument une corde
supplémentaire faite pour vibrer à 880
hertz
cette nouvelle note elle sonnera bien
avec la première qu'on avait déjà et
cette harmonie entre les deux notes elle
va aussi fonctionner avec d'autres
systèmes de production du son un on peut
regarder par exemple ce que ça donne
avec un tuyau d'orgue
[Musique]
non
ça sonne bien non
et bien c'est parce qu'il ya un principe
physique qui fait que ça fonctionne et
ça sonne même tellement bien que pour
notre cerveau ces deux notes c'est
quasiment la même
on dit que la deuxième note celle octave
de la première mais cette nouvelle note
on peut à son tour doublé sa fréquence
pour obtenir une note de fréquences qui
le quadruple de celle de départ qui
sonnera bien aussi avec les deux autres
puis à nouveau pour obtenir 8 fois la
fréquence etc
mais inversement on peut aussi divisés
la fréquence de départ par deux bah oui
si une note sont harmonieusement avec sa
fréquence doublent notre 440 hertz de
départ il sonnera aussi bien avec sa
moitié 2 120 hertz et aussi son quart
110r tsé tsé et voilà on a construit
plein de nouvelles notes pour notre
instrument et comme ces notes elles sont
toutes à peu près pareil on va
collectivement les appeler notre numéro
un
alors ça c'est très bien mais faire de
la musique avec une seule note même sur
différentes octave ça va être quand même
assez chiant
[Musique]
pourquoi
est ce qu'on peut faire mieux et
enrichir un peu notre instrument et ben
oui on peut et on va à nouveau faire
appel à des principes physiques
on a vu qu'un objet qui produit du son à
la fréquence f produit aussi
naturellement du son à la fréquence 2 f
et bien pour les mêmes raisons il va
aussi un petit peu vibrer à la fréquence
3f qu'on appelle la troisième harmonique
en repartant de notre note de départ 1
440 hertz la fréquence 3f c'est 1300
verte
c'est une nouvelle note qu'on n'avait
pas jusqu'ici et donc on peut la
rajouter à notre instrument écoutez ça
c'est vraiment une note qui est
différente de la grotte numéro un mais
qui sonne harmonieusement à nos oreilles
[Musique]
cette nouvelle note on va l'appeler
notre numéro deux et on dit que c'est la
quinte de la note numéro un et on peut à
son tour lui appliquer le principe des
octaves et créer de nouvelles fréquences
en divisant et en multipliant par deux
en particulier en divisant 1320 par deux
on obtient 660 r ce qui est une note qui
est plus proche de notre note de départ
et au final on obtient le lien entre les
deux en multipliant par trois demis et
les deux sunday ensemble donc
[Musique]
et
on a maintenant deux notes vraiment
différente sur notre instrument et pour
aller plus loin et ben on peut
simplement appliquer le principe de la
quinte à la note numéro 2 et créer comme
ça là notre numéro trois si on multiplie
la fréquence de la note numéro 2 par 3
demi on obtient 990 hertz qu'on peut
comme toujours multiplier ou divisé par
deux pour faire les octaves de cette
nouvelle note est en particulier on
passe de 660 à 495 hertz en multipliant
par trois quarts grâce au principe d
octave passer d'une note à une autre en
multipliant par trois à trois demis ou
trois quarts ça revient au même
donc je fais l'un ou l'autre camp ça
m'arrange pour créer encore plein de
nouvelles notamment un instrument bas on
n'a plus qu'à répéter ce principe de
passage à la quinte la note numéro 3 a
été obtenue comme la quinte de la noc
numéro 2 ensuite on construit la note
numéro 4 comme cairns de la note numéro
3 puis la numéro 5 la numéro 6 et cetera
bon bah c'est super on a maintenant
plein de nouvelles notes pour notre
instrument et qui sont basées sur un
principe physique qui assure que chaque
note va bien sonné avec sa quinte
mais du coup on fait ça indéfiniment on
rajoute des notes à l'infini et bien non
parce qu'un véritable miracle se produit
quand on fait ça pour la douzième fois
on retombe sur des fréquences qui sont
très proches de notre note de départ
regardez là et là ça veut dire que la
quinte de la note numéro 12
celle qu'on aurait envie d'appeler la
note numéro 13 eh ben c'est quasiment la
note numéro un et donc n'a pas besoin de
rajouter une 13e note ou une 14e ou les
suivantes
on peut se limiter à 12 notes au lieu de
représenter les enchaînements de quinte
en ligne ben on représente ça en cercle
sous forme d'un cycle au bout de 12 15
on retombe sur la note numéro un
c'est-à-dire qu'on boucle on appelle
cette figure le cycle des quintes et
c'est donc ça qui explique qu'on est que
12 notes sur un instrument de musique
les douze touches du piano ou bien les
douze fred de la guitare est ce qui est
important de comprendre c'est que ce
petit miracle se produit quelle que soit
la note de départ
là j'ai choisi 440 hertz mais j'aurais
bien pu prendre n'importe quoi ça aurait
fonctionné le fait qu'au bout de 12 15
successives on retombe sur la note de
départ ça vient en fait d'une égalité
mathématiques quand on prend la quinte
on multiplie la fréquence par trois
demis et si on fait ça à 12 fois de
suite
on tombe sur une fréquence qui est 3/2
puissance 12 fois la fréquence de départ
or trois demis puissance douce si on
calcule ça vaut 100 29.7 c'est très
proche de 128 qui est depuis 107 et
vous rappelle une multiplication par 2
c'est un passage à l'octave donc deux
puissances 7
c'est cette octave au dessus de la note
de départ donc prendre douze fois la
quinte
c'est quasiment comme prendre cette
octave et du coup le miracle du fait que
le cycle des quintes boucle au bout de
douze coups enfin donc le presque vient
d'une presque égalité mathématiques 3/2
puissance 12 à peu près égale à deux
puissances 7 ou autrement dit trois
puissances 12 à peu près égale à deux
puissances 19
le problème dans cette histoire c'est le
presque parce que cette égalité
mathématiques elle n'est pas exactement
vrai et donc le cycle des quintes ne
boucle pas exactement retombe pas
parfaitement sur nos pieds et ça il va
falloir en tenir compte
[Musique]
si on se base sur le cycle des cartes
pour créer les notes dont on va avoir
besoin pour notre instrument on va avoir
un petit problème pour créer les
fréquences de nos notes on multiplie à
chaque étape par trois demis ou trois
quarts c'est pareil et on fait ça on se
voit de suite donc normalement la can de
la 12e note s'obtient en multipliant à
nouveau par trois demis et devrait
valoir 446 hertz si on prend la note 1 à
la place qui est 440 c'est pas tout à
fait la quinte
c'est à dire que cette qu'un cela sera
un peu trop courte et on l'obtient en
multipliant par 1,48 au lieu de 1,5 r3
demie au total si on fait ça on aura
donc 11 15 qui seront parfaitement
justes et une qui sera un peu fausse et
il va falloir assumer ça cette manière
de déterminer la fréquence des notes
qu'on va utiliser donc la façon
d'accorder nos instruments
on l'appelle l'accord pythagoriciens et
donc on l'a vu il aura toujours une
quinte un peu fou on appelle ça la
quinte du bien simplement l'umih parce
que même pour une oreille pas trop
exercer elle s'entend vraiment elle crée
un espèce de battement qui rappelle le
hurlement de l'animal écoutez par
exemple avec un son d'orgue
voici d'abord un accord de quinte juste
et maintenant un accord de kindu
[Musique]
ça fait mal aux oreilles et bains
jusqu'au 15ème siècle c'est cette
manière d'accorder les instruments qu'on
utilisait et donc tous les instruments
avait un loup sauf que on a la liberté
de choisir à quel endroit du cycle des
cadres on va mettre le loup est donc
généralement ont planqué ça dans un
intervalle qui était pas trop utiliser
du genre la bémol libé molle c'était une
manière de cacher un peu la misère mais
du coup pendant toute cette période
l'obligation d'éviter le loup
restreignait la liberté des
instrumentistes et des compositeurs mais
surtout à pareloup il ya un autre
problème avec l'accord pythagoriciens on
a vu que naturellement à cause de la
manière dont vivre les objets
si on a une fréquence f la fréquence de
zf sonne bien avec celle octave ainsi
que la fréquence 3 f
c'est la quinte enfin pour la même
raison la fréquence 4f faudra bien aussi
ça c'est normal ces deux octaves au
dessus mais on peut aller un cran plus
loin et regarder la fréquence 5 f 5 f
ou bien en descendant d'octavin la
fréquence 5 2002 f ou cinq cars 2 fc
paris là par rapport à la note de départ
on appelle cette fréquence la tierce
majeur si on prend notre fréquence de
base de 440 hertz la tierce majeur donc
cinq cartes sera donc à 550 hertz alors
écoutons ce que ça donne
[Musique]
m
e
[Musique]
ça sonne bien non alors à ce stade on
pourrait se dire que ça fait une
nouvelle note qui va falloir qu'on
rajoute à notre instrument à la longue
liste de notes qu'on avait déjà mais ce
qui est amusant c'est que si on regarde
ce qu'on avait construit avec le cycle
des quintes on se rend compte que cette
fréquence
on l'avait déjà enfin presque regardez
après 4,15 successives
on est tombé sur la fréquence 557 hertz
quasiment la tierce majeur qui a 500 50
hertz a priori c'est quelque chose
d'assez miraculeux à nouveau un dans
notre construction précédentes on
souciait pas du tout la tierce
mais on l'a naturellement fabriqué en
prenant des cartes successives et la
raison pour laquelle ça marche c'est que
x 5 est presque égale à multiplier par
trois demis puissance 4 qui vaut 5,06
sauf qu'une fois de plus sa tombe pas
tout à fait juste un on à 557 hertz
alors qu'on voulait 550 hertz est donc
dans le système de l'accord
pythagoriciens on a bien des tierces
mais qui sont un peu fausse qui sont un
peu trop large et ça s'entend écouter
[Musique]
le fait que la tiers se soit légèrement
faux dans l'accord pythagoriciens fait
qu'avant le xvème siècle elle n'était
pas considéré comme un intervalle juste
du compte l'utiliser pour ainsi dire pas
vraiment elles n'ont été considérés
comme des consonances imparfaite que
bien plus tardivement
il faut dire que tant l'accord
pythagoriciens la tierce majeur est plus
haute que la tire se dit pur à cette
époque on favorisait les octaves les
quintes et les cartes les intervalles
dit parfait sur lesquels sont basés
l'accord pythagoriciens en sommes et qui
forme les premières harmonique dans son
[Musique]
d'ailleurs fun fact les intervalles de
quinta vides sont très régulièrement
utilisé dans les accompagnements dans le
rock ou dans le métal on appelle ça un
power corp d'où un acord puissance et sa
une sonorité hyper brut aux alentours du
15e siècle
certains musiciens ont commencé à
reconnaître la valeur harmonique de la
tierce des révisions de la manière
d'accorder les instruments ont très vite
suivi donc dans le système
pythagoriciens basée uniquement sur les
quintes belle et fière se sont
légèrement fausses elles sont un tout
petit peu trop grande
une solution pour essayer de corriger ce
problème c'est de conserver le principe
du cycle des quintes mais de raccourcir
très légèrement toutes les cartes de
manière à ce que les tierces tombe
parfaitement juste pour que ça marche
assez simple pour passer à la quinte au
lieu de multiplier par trois demis qui
vont 1,5
on va multiplier par cinq puissances un
car qui vaut 1,495 la quinte quasiment
juste mais cette fois au bout de 4 quand
on a une tierce majeur qui cette fois
est parfaite
cette manière d'accorder les instruments
s'appelle le tempérament mais au tonic
et il repose donc sur un compromis un
petit sacrifice c'est à dire que les
quintes deviennent très légèrement
fausse mais pour un bénéfice notable les
tierces devienne parfaitement juste et
donc par exemple pour un accord majeur
qui est composé d'une note de satire ce
majeur et de sa quinte ça passe beaucoup
mieux
le seul problème avec le tempérament
mais au tonic c'est qu'on a toujours le
problème du loucedé repos le cycle se
referme pas tout à fait il est même en
fait encore plus grave
et même il faut certaines des tierces
parmi les moins utilisés vers la fin du
xvème siècle les tempéraments mais
atomiques sont apparus en musique
à une époque on a voulu favoriser la
tierce il a donc fallu trouver un
nouveau compromis entre des tiers juste
et des quintes pas trop fosse est en
réalité il n'existe pas un tempérament
mais atomique mais des tempéraments mais
au tonic qui consiste en différents
degrés de justesse des différents
intervalles du fait que les tierces
majeur deviennent parfaite et les
quintes légèrement fausses cela a bien
sûr eu un impact sur la manière de
composer en stimulant l'utilisation des
tierces et en décourageant un peu la
quinta vide qui était pourtant largement
utilisé au moyen âge
de plus à cause de la présence de la
carte du loup et de 4/3 sauce les quatre
qui passe par le loup le compositeur
avait tendance à rester dans les mêmes
tonalités de la fa sol si bémol ray pas
de problème mais les compositeurs
éditait la bémol eni bémol parce que
cette analyse et et les triades
correspondante ce n'est un peu mais pour
certains jouer la musique de la
renaissance et les premières musiques
baroques sans utiliser cette manière
d'accorder les instruments c'est trahir
la couleur de la musique dans l'esprit
du compositeur
alors à ce stade on pourrait se demander
s'il n'ya pas un moyen d'avoir le beurre
et l'argent du beurre c'est à dire un
système où à la fois les quintes et
laitière ce serait parfaitement juste
ben on peut essayer pour être concret je
vais revenir au nom des notes qu'on
connaît et je vais vous notez les
fréquences
imaginons qu'on parle d'un fait 350 de
hertz on fabrique sa quinte parfaite le
dos à 528 hertz en multipliant par trois
demies on fabrique aussi ça tire ses
nageurs parfaite le la à 440 en
multipliant par cinq quarts puis en
prenant soin la tierce parfaite du dos
soit la quinte du là on tombe sur le me
bats jusqu'ici tout va bien tout est
parfaitement juste en prenant la quinte
du dos on tombe sur le sol
la tierce du sol c'est le psy qu'on
obtient aussi comme 15 du mit et la
quinte du sol c'est leur est là vous
voyez qu'on a fabriqué les sept notes de
la gamme de do majeur sans faire aucune
approximation et aucun compromis
à ce stade il faudrait encore ajouter
les diesels et bémol mais même sans
aller jusque là en fait on a déjà un
problème j'ai créé ces notes de la cape
de dôme et maintenant imaginer que je
veuille jouer en gamme de ré pour jouer
en vrai je peux partir de celui-ci un
jeu l'est je vais avoir besoin de ça
1 tu es normalement c'est le là on
pourrait se dire qu'on l'a déjà ici un
et le problème c'est que cela là n'est
pas la carte parfaite durée c'est
l'attirance parfaite du fâ ce qui est
pas tout à fait la même chose celui ci
s'obtient en prenant une tierce à partir
du fa et celui là 4 quinte à partir du
phare et une tierce parfaite ou 4
qu'imparfaite bas on l'a vu c'est pas
tout à fait pareil
en bref même si on arrive à accorder
notre instrument parfaitement pour jouer
en gamme de dos là dès qu'on veut
changer de gamme
on est coincé cette manière d'accorder
les instruments on l'appelle parfois
juste naturel bien l'accordage des
physiciens
le problème c'est qu'on peut pas
transposer la musique ou jouer dans des
gammes différentes
à moins de changer d'accordage à chaque
fois qu'on change de tonalité la raison
pour laquelle ça peut pas marcher est la
même que pour le cycle des quintes on a
un problème de bouclage
la différence c'est qu'ici on fabrique
des notes en utilisant à la fois la
carte et la tierce
donc on fait plus une ligne comme dans
le cycle des quintes mais un réseau de
notes en deux dimensions
on appelle ça parfois le taux net et le
taux net que techniquement on voudrait
refermer non pas en cercle mais sous
forme d'un tort eh ben ils ne se referme
pas parfaitement de même que le cycle
dès qu'un pneu bouclé pas parfaitement
alors petite remarque au passage ce
qu'on vient de raconter là c'est vrai
pour les instruments qui ont un
accordage fixe comme un piano ou une
guitare mais sur un instrument qui peut
jouer toutes les fréquences continûment
balle instrumentistes à la liberté de
jouer différemment une certaine note
suivant la gamme dans laquelle on joue
c'est vrai par exemple pour les cordes
ou bien le trombone à coulisse mais
c'est aussi particulièrement vrai pour
le chant un chanteur ou une chanteuse
qui en a la maîtrise technique peut
choisir de chanter très légèrement
différemment
1la suivant qu'il apparaît par exemple
comme la tierce du fâ dans un accord de
femmes majeures ou bien comme la quinte
dur est bon mais maintenant on va
essayer de voir quelle est la solution
moderne à tous ces problèmes d'accordage
[Musique]
ce qu'il faut bien réaliser c'est que
tous ces petits problèmes qu'on a pour
accorder les instruments et ben ils
peuvent pas avoir de solution parfaite
c'est lié à l'arithmétique trois
puissances 12 s'est pas exactement de
puissance 19 et 3000 puissance 4 c'est
pas exactement 5
donc de toute façon on aura toujours un
souci on peut pas accorder un instrument
de manière à ce que tout soit toujours
juste dans toutes les gammes
c'est mort mais est ce qu'on peut faire
c'est essayer de répartir un peu le
désaccord de manière à ce que tout soit
à peu près correct la solution moderne
qu'on utilise aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on
appelle le tempérament égale les ça
consiste à répartir le désaccord de
manière homogène sur tout les notes de
manière à ce que ça s'entende pas trop
alors voilà comment on fait on sait
qu'avec par exemple l'accord
pythagoriciens entre une note et son
octave on trouve 12 notes intermédiaires
et ben on va simplement décidé que pour
passer d'une note à la suivante on
multiplie toujours par deux puissances
un 12e et du coup au bout de douze coups
on retombe pile sur l'octave et on
trouve des valeurs qui sont assez
proches de celles qu'on avait avant la
can s'obtient au bout de sept coups et
vos deux puissances cette 12e qui est
1,498 donc vraiment très très proche de
3 2 me la tierce obtient au bout de cinq
coups et vos deux puissances 5/12 qui
est 1,26 soient assez proches de 5 car
en répartissant le désaccord sur tous
les intervalles on arrive à cacher la
misère et à éviter par exemple les
problèmes de boue alors dans le fond à
part l'octave tous les intervalles sont
très légèrement faux mais de manière
parfaitement uniforme et en plus toutes
les tonalités se valent et sont traités
à la même enseigne
le fait que toutes les tonalités soit
utilisable et notamment ce que jean
sébastien bach a essayé de démontrer
dans son clavier bien tempéré qui est un
véritable terrain de jeu puisqu'il y
composent deux pièces dans chacune des
tonalités possible
[Musique]
à
mais contrairement à ce qu'on entend
souvent bac n'utilisait pas le
tempérament égale qui est l'invention
plus récente mais une manière d'accorder
les instruments extrêmement proches
probablement l'une de celles inventées
par un de ses contemporains werckmeister
le tempérament de werckmeister essaie
lui aussi de répartir la dissonance
surtout les intervalles mais pas de
manière homogène dans ce tempérament
toutes les tonalités sonne bien mais
elle ne sonne pas tout exactement pareil
comme dans le tempérament égal et c'est
notamment l'esprit du clavier bien
tempéré composé de prélude et de fugue
dans les douze tonalités majeures et les
douze tonalité mineure
si on joue ses oeuvres avec un
tempérament de werckmeister cela fait
ressortir les différentes colorations
spécifiques de chaque tonalité c'est
légère coloration disparaissent à partir
du moment où on joue avec un tempérament
égal dans la mesure où toutes les
tonalités se valent il est important
d'insister sur une chose il sera
probablement toujours question de
compromis pour avoir la plus grande
liberté compositionnel le tempérament
égal et de loin le pire des tempéraments
de tous dans la mesure où il ne comporte
aucun l'intervalle juste à l'exception
de l'octa bien sûr mais c'est également
le meilleur puisqu'il ne comporte aucun
intervalle terriblement faux aujourd'hui
sauf exception l'accordage par
tempérament égal et la méthode qu'on
utilise pour accorder tous les
instruments enfin du moins dans la
musique occidentale traditionnel parce
qu'en fait il ya plein d'autres manières
de faire qui ont été explorés par
certains compositeurs ou bien dans
certaines régions du monde la musique
arabe par exemple utilise fréquemment 24
note au lieu de 12 en divisant
simplement chaque intervalle en deux
pour créer d'écarts de taux
[Musique]
la musique indienne on utilise 22 qu'on
appelle les shoots i
[Musique]
il existe aussi d'autres manières de
diviser l'octave par exemple en 19 note
au lieu de 12
un système comme ça très différemment
les dièses et les bémols et donc par
exemple contrairement à ce qu'on a sur
un piano un ré dièse seraient traités
différemment d'un mi bémol certains
compositeurs contemporains comme joël
mandelbaum joseph ya soeur ou yves ordaz
règles ont écrit des pièces pour ce type
de musique écouté la sonorité de ce
morceau
[Musique]
donc
et on pourrait pousser encore plus loin
par exemple en divisant l'octave en 31
ou 53 intervalle toutes ses manières de
faire font partie de ce qu'on appelle la
musique micro tonale c'est à dire la
musique qui utilisent des intervalles
qui sont plus petits que les 12 demi ton
habituel ça reste un style assez
marginal mais il arrive parfois que ça
soit utilisé dans la musique populaire
écoutez par exemple l'introduction de ce
morceau de radiohead
je trouve que ça donne une sacrée
ambiance au morceau en tout cas merci
d'avoir suivi cette vidéo merci beaucoup
à blaye qui a fait le plaisir de venir
m'aider et vous pouvez bien sûr allez
vous abonner à sa chaîne le ce est
barrée et vous pouvez aussi le retrouver
sur la tronche en biais si vous voulez
avoir les activer la chaînes vous pouvez
retrouver sur facebook et sur twitter
est ce qu'il faut être peux me souvenir
sur tipi merci à bientôt
[Musique]